bienvenidos de nuevo antes de seguir con
ideas acerca de cómo aumentar nuestras
finanzas nuestra economía cómo comprar
una casa pues es así lo que quiero ver
es la curva de rendimiento y usted que
seguramente antes lo han oído entonces
la idea de este vídeo seguir creando
herramientas que nos sirvan para
entender más acerca de procesos que
tienen que ver con finanzas y economía
la curva de rendimiento y en este caso
voy a hablar de la curva de rendimiento
de la tesorería a qué se refiere todo
esto seguramente tú lo has oído antes
puede ser que les escucharon algún canal
de negocios o no hayas escuchado de
algún tipo de banco pero lo que sí estoy
seguro es que en los siguientes cinco o
diez minutos que dure este vídeo tú vas
a saber un buen acerca de la curva de
rendimiento pero qué se refiere esto de
tesorería bueno cuando yo hablo acerca
de valores de la tesorería o de bonos de
la tesorería o de notas de la tesorería
notas de la tesorería me estoy
refiriendo a deudas que tiene el
gobierno y estas deudas son considerados
libres de riesgo pues si tú le prestas
dinero al gobierno federal y ellos
necesitan ese dinero todo lo que tienen
que hacer
los impuestos y con ello pagarte la
deuda que tenían contigo así que en
términos de la tesorería todas estas
notas valores y bonos son deudas que si
el gobierno obtiene contigo son deudas
seguras pues recibirás tarde o temprano
tu respectivo pago es por eso que quiero
analizar esta ocasión la curva de
rendimiento de la tesorería y también
justo por lo que acabamos de ver es una
curva que está libre de riesgo es decir
como de cualquier manera tú vas a
recuperar tu dinero entonces no tiene el
riesgo de perderlo ahora bien antes de
seguir vamos a entrar las las
definiciones bueno lo primero que me
gustaría ver es cuál es la diferencia
entre un valor de la tesorería una nota
de la tesorería o un bono de la
tesorería si se dan cuenta estas tres
son deudas de la tesorería es decir del
gobierno pero en que se diferencia una
de la otra
bueno las respuestas que se diferencian
en la cantidad del tiempo en la cual te
van a pagar por ejemplo si tú le prestas
el banco mil pesos y se lo prestas
durante seis meses entonces estamos
hablando acerca de un valor de la
tesorería
es decir nos referimos a un valor de la
tesorería cuando nosotros le prestamos
dinero al gobierno de cero a un año
bueno de hecho deseo no se podría tendrá
que ser mayor que cero y menor que un
año es un valor de la tesorería ahora
bien hablamos de una nota de la
tesorería cuando nosotros le prestamos
el gobierno una cierta cantidad de
dinero desde un año mayor o igual a un
año y hasta diez años eso es lo que se
refiere una nota de tesorería así que
mejor vamos apuntando lo de una vez un
valor de la tesorería es un préstamo que
tú le hace al gobierno de cero a un año
bueno de hecho de cero no se podría yo
creo que el préstamo más pequeño que tú
le podrías hacer al gobierno desde un
mes de un mes a un año es un valor de la
tesorería ahora bien desde un año hasta
diez años y aquí contando el año es
decir mayor o igual a un año hasta diez
años es una nota de la tesorería si te
das cuenta los dos son deudas del
gobierno los dos son una cantidad de
dinero que tú estás prestando el
gobierno sin embargo se diferencian en
la cantidad de tiempo en la cual te van
a pagar y bueno a partir de diez años en
adelante se llama un bono de la
tesorería y ya con esto podemos saber
cuál es
entre estos tres conceptos que yo tenía
aquí y así podemos distinguir uno del
otro
ahora bien la siguiente pregunta que
quiero que veamos es esta los tres
conceptos que acabamos de ver tienen la
misma tasa de interés o de que va a
depender la tasa de interés que te va a
pagar el banco por el dinero prestado y
bueno lo primero que podemos ver es que
eso va a depender del riesgo por ejemplo
si le prestamos una cantidad de dinero
al gobierno durante 30 años en 30 años
puede pasar un mal de cosas por ejemplo
puede cambiar del gobierno del país o
podría cambiar del partido político del
país o en su dado caso podría haber una
guerra o se puede acabar el mundo no lo
sabemos pero en 30 años pueden pasar un
buen de cosas por lo tanto hay más
riesgo de que ese dinero le pueda pasar
algo ahora que me acuerdo antes de
seguir hablando él es de riesgo me
gustaría aclararles algo si yo comparo
un préstamo que le doy al banco durante
un mes y un préstamo que le doy al banco
durante un año después de aparecer que
yo gano mucho más dinero si prestó el
dinero durante un mes porque porque ese
cierto mes tendría una cierta tasa de
interés y acabado ese mes pues yo vuelvo
a prestarle el dinero al banco durante
otro mes y tengo la misma tasa interés y
así sucesivamente y entonces de una
trampa
y entonces para que no suceda esto es lo
que suele pasar es lo siguiente se habla
de una tasa de interés anual si
prestamos el dinero durante 10 años es
una tasa de interés anual si prestamos
el dinero durante un mes es una tasa
interés anual todo se soluciona si
ponemos desde un inicio una tasa una
cierta tasa de interés anual bueno pero
regresamos a los riesgos que otros
riesgos podrían pasar por ejemplo la
inflación es un riesgo el colapso del
dólar o de la manera de tu país otro
ejemplo es necesitar el dinero o podría
pasar que ese dinero no podrías usar en
una mejor inversión no sé todos estos
son riesgos todo esto nos hace pensar
que en general hay mejores tasas de
interés en un periodo largo de tiempo
que en un periodo corto de tiempo y para
que se note todo esto mucho más claro
voy a utilizar la página de la tesorería
de eeuu en donde dice que en el mes de
marzo del 2008 en el día 14 de marzo del
2008 por poner un ejemplo pero esta
página se actualiza día tras día y sólo
para poner un ejemplo voy a utilizar el
14 de marzo y si se dan cuenta lo que
hice aquí es que si nosotros le
prestamos dinero al gobierno el día
de marzo entonces ellos me van a dar un
datacenter es del 1.2 por ciento todos
estos datos son muy útiles porque los
voy a graficar precisamente con todos
estos datos voy a crear la curva del
rendimiento entonces fíjense que en tres
meses tenemos una paciente desde un
poquito menos 1.18 por ciento y si
nosotros nos damos cuenta que es lo que
pasa en mucho tiempo por ejemplo en
siete años tenemos la tasa interés del
2.84 por ciento en 30 años del 4.35 por
ciento en seis meses del 1.32 por ciento
y con todo esto vamos a construir
cuidadosamente la curva de rendimiento
entonces en uno de los ejes voy a tener
la cantidad de tiempo como ya lo
habíamos visto y en el otro eje voy a
tener la tasa de interés por ejemplo
quienes tenemos una tasa de interés del
1.20 por ciento y por lo tanto voy a
poner este punto que tenemos aquí en
tres meses tenemos una tasa de 1.18 un
poquito menos en seis meses aumentaba mi
tasa interés a 1.32 por ciento en un año
aumentaba mi tasa de interés a 1.37 por
ciento y en cinco años es cuando ya se
disparaba en cinco años tenemos una tasa
interés de 2.37 por ciento
diez años y recordábamos tenemos como
344 voy a checar otra vez porque no lo
recuerdo bien si es 344 entonces en 10
años tenemos una tasa interés de 3.44
por ciento en 20 años tenemos una tasa
de interés de 4.30 por ciento y en 30
años que es lo más que se podía teníamos
una docente de 4.35 por ciento y por lo
tanto ya tenemos nuestra curva de
rendimiento si unimos todos los puntos
vamos a obtener nuestra tan esperada
curva de rendimiento de la tesorería y
recuerden que era una curva de
rendimiento fuera de riesgo y ya está
aquí en nuestra curva de rendimiento y
espero que te haya quedado claro para
qué sirve una curva de rendimiento una
curva de rendimiento sirve para
enseñarnos las distintas tasas de
interés que tenemos si nosotros le
prestamos dinero al gobierno durante
distintos periodos de tiempo y para cada
periodo de tiempo vamos a obtener una
tasa center es distinta y más aún en
esta curva de rendimiento que les acabo
de enseñar se ve claramente que a mayor
tiempo una mayor tasa de interés y a
menor tiempo una menor tasa de interés y
esto se ve muy claro porque cuando
nosotros hicimos la gráfica de esta
curva no salió
la curva ascendente y esto es muy
importante pues nos muestra que a mayor
cantidad de tiempo tenemos mayor riesgo
y por lo tanto mayor interés ahora bien
otra pregunta que sería bueno analizar
es ver por qué tiene esta tasa de
interés es decir porque está determinada
con esta forma la curva de rendimiento
bueno cuando la tesorería es decir el
gobierno necesita recolectar dinero o
pedir prestado dinero va a decir lo
siguiente hey necesitamos conseguir un
billón de pesos porque no sé por qué no
sabemos controlar nuestros gastos y
entonces se le ocurre hacer notas de
tesorería con fecha de vencimiento de un
mes para recolectar este billón de pesos
y entonces tienen una subasta y el mundo
nos e investigadores de donde sea o todo
el que está interesado en invertir todos
ellos van a ver si es un lugar seguro
para invertir su dinero durante un mes y
aquí viene lo interesante pues
dependiendo de la demanda es decir de la
cantidad de gente que falla la subasta
será la tasa de interés si hay mucha
mucha gente que quiere invertir su
dinero en estos pagarés mensuales la
tasa de interés será un poco menor esto
ese sentido para ti
por eso voy a poner este punto aquí y de
manera similar de manera muy análoga si
la gente no quiere invertir en tu país
no sé supongamos que ellos piensan que
puedes quedarles mal en tu deuda algún
día o lo que sea y entonces casi no hay
gente que quiera invertir en tu
tesorería entonces el gobierno o sea eso
ocurre que tendrá que pagar una mayor
tasa de interés para que la gente se
fije y para que la gente preste su
dinero a este país
finalmente supongamos que las subastas
tienen distintas duraciones ya lo que me
refiero con distintas duraciones es en
la fecha de vencimiento de pagaré es
decir un mes tres meses un año diez años
treinta años etcétera pero una vez que
el gobierno hace su subasta el gobierno
te tiene que entregar tu respectivo
pagaré y bueno en términos generales
dependiendo de la demanda de la gente
que quiera invertir en ese país va a
depender la tasa de interés que vaya a
existir a mayor demanda de las personas
que quieran invertir la tasa de interés
va a bajar ya menor demanda de personas
que quieran invertir en ese gobierno la
tasa de interés va a aumentar y bueno
aunque me gustaría contarles más cosas
acerca de la curva de rendimiento y tal
vez haga otro vídeo de ello lo que sí
quiero decirles es que ya estoy
corriendo en tiempo
y espero que les haya servido este vídeo
para saber cuál es la diferencia entre
una nota un valor y un bono de la
tesorería y la curva de rendimiento